Trump and diplomacy
go together America's president doesn't
seem that bothered by international
relations in the traditional sense my
foreign policy will always put the
interests of the American people and
American security above always there's a
temperamental issue of course navigating
the intricacies of global affairs
requires nuance subtlety finally argued
points none of those are obvious Trump
strengths from this day forward it's
going to be only America first
there are also ideological issues too
this is a man who wants to slash foreign
aid budgets who wanted to build walls
who wants to dismantle trade agreements
his guiding principle is America first
sums presence on the world stage shall
we say disruptive I've been a whole
range for relatively small and amusing
like that really old 19 second handshake
with japan's Prime Minister Shinzo
Arvind
and who could forget that moment with
Theresa May when they walk down the ramp
outside the White House he's also
managed to hang up on the Australian
Prime Minister and deeply offended China
when he accepted a phone call from
Taiwan's president this is the United
States of America that I'm representing
I'm not representing the globe but Trump
faces some much more serious questions
and challenges his position on Russia is
far from clear he decided to intervene
in Syria after that chemical weapons
attack and as a growing issue with North
Korea Hillary Clinton once said of Trump
a man you can beat with a tweet is not a
man you can trust with nuclear weapons
well now he's in the Oval Office
contemplating an escalating nuclear
crisis